im april hat der kinderkanal von ard und
zdf kika eine neue serie gestartet sie
heißt völlig meschugge google hebräisch
für verrückt die geschichte von drei
freunden die sich in ihrem schulalltag
mit mobbing und antisemitismus
auseinander setzen müssen ein
ambitioniert ist ein gutes projekt
die frage ist allerdings ob sich der
kicker nicht auch mit
israelfeindlichkeit in den eigenen
reihen auseinandersetzen muss
schreie vermummte personen teilweise
bewaffnet mit steinen anti israel demo
in palästina mittendrin dieser mann
teilnehmer des israel-feindlichen
jugendfestivals in vater im
westjordanland und moderator beim
öffentlich-rechtlichen fernsehsender
kieker
hallo der tages rom es ist baumhaus zeit
matondo castro eines der gesichter der
serie das baumhaus auf dem kindersender
soll der kleinen kindern wissen und
werte vermitteln in palästina nimmt er
an israel feindlichen demonstrationen
teil und verbringt zeit mit kerim
schamberger dieser ist ein selbst
ernannter kommunist und unterstützer der
anti israelischen boykottbewegung bds
also die bewegung die den staat israel
wirtschaftlich politisch und kulturell
isolieren will und sein existenzrecht
infrage stellt dass israel feindliche
jugend festival würde auf der website
kommunisten de vorgestellt und mit
matondo castros teilnahme beworben zwei
absätze weiter schreiben sie über die
sogenannte apartheids aufschrei empörung
bei der öffentlich rechtlichen
sendeanstalt es wäre überraschend denn
es scheint das gebührenfinanzierte
fernsehen ist auf dem antisemitismus
auge blind
nene al hassan antisemitismus vorfall
sorgte deutschlandweit für schlagzeilen
die 28 jährige sollte die wissenschaft
sendung quarks auf dem wdr moderieren
doch kurz vor beginn ihrer
öffentlich-rechtlichen karriere enthüllt
bild el hassan nimmt im jahr 2014 am
berliner alkmaar steil eine
antisemitische hetze veranstaltung auf
der kippa tragen die juden angegriffen
und die vernichtung israels gefordert
wurde damit nicht genug bei social media
unterstützte sie beiträge über die
ermordung eines juden daraufhin nahm der
wdr abstand von der geplanten
zusammenarbeit
unvergessen auch die anti israel demo in
berlin mai vergangenen jahres mehr als
3000 männer und frauen strömen auf die
straßen skandieren antisemitische
parolen wie scheiß jude und tel aviv
bombardierte
israel
in neukölln und die tagesthemen
viele teilnehmende wollten deutlich
machen dass sie gewalt in nahost
verurteilen ganz offensichtlich israel
feindliche personen durften zur besten
sendezeit zu wort kommen antisemitismus
israel feindlichkeit und ignoranz beim
öffentlich rechtlichen fernsehen
empörung gibt es dafür auch aus der
politik das inakzeptabel und frage mich
manchmal was schief gestrickt ist wenn
man sich die lage an schaut israel
einziges land mit menschenrechten
demokratie und gleichberechtigung im
gesamten nahen osten auch im vergleich
zu palästina und trotzdem kommt das
selbsternannte bollwerk für demokratie
und gegen extremismus wie der öffentlich
rechtliche rundfunk sich bezeichnet da
seinen ansprüchen nicht im ansatz
hinterher auf bild anfrage teilt kicker
mit dem fall kassel prüfen zu wollen der
sender kenne den 28 jährigen als
personen die sich deutlich gegen hass
und gewalt positioniert
[Musik]